les chéris il ya des beaux cadeaux dans
les boîtes mails ya surtout un beau
cadeau c'est des boîtes les boîtes
spéciales cinéma regardez ce qui vous
attend il y a le maquillage du joker
mais le petit déj du ch'nord non c'est
le bon usage des bronzés un boire de la
potion magique
ah non ce faire la tête de the mask se
déguisant jacquouille on se faire
modifier mais il dégage une heure trente
dans un parc avec isabelle le jura les
billets d'avion pour new york
si les shérifs après une journée à
londres avec moi et quatre stars
d'hollywood dont margot robbie les
chéris on va démarrer tout de suite par
la première boîte la boîte numéro une
isabelle morini bosc
j'avais choisi la boîte numéros unes
pendant la pub ils ont choisi les boîtes
ouais isabelle est ce que vous allez
partir avec moi à londres
regardez la une moi je me le fais mais
je vous souhaite pas même éclaté l'été
mais ce serait bien
alors là oui il a raison mais alors là
une chaussure
oui parce que c'est madame c'est mon
jour pasqua vous êtes né en 1910 à
isabelle magnifique ma chérie payer la
tête de the mask astérix et obélix boire
la potion magique où par hasard ce
cadeau là vous allez voir isabelle ou le
rail
vous allez voir de la potion magique
attention les amis acadiana c'est
dégueulasse mais non mais non c'est quoi
et on sait pas ce qu'il ya dedans mais
c'est bon ça va je sens non mais sérieux
j'ai perdu tous les autres sens mais moi
ce l'odeur isabelle homogène il sera pas
là et sera pas toujours là où bat que
vous serez dit et je vous dirai ce que
vous savez vous la boîte où il ya le
voyage avec moi non non on va mal à
communiquer elle va revenir sa valise a
très bien fait quoi attention la boit
super sale et venteux n'y a pas de
numéro deux la syrah jean malié est ce
que vous sentez bien savez que j'ai vécu
à londres
j'aimerais bien partir avec vous êtes
sympas la conversation oui c'est vrai
j'apporterai des bouquins ouais on a
bradé finale et j'espère que c'est pas
ça là il va partir changer
oui bien sûr alors non je garde la deux
oui tous pourris sont 94 à 2 looseuses
oui je te le confirme et riches prennent
elles luttent en mer
je suis vouloir celle là non je vais
changer
ah oui oui vous les laquelle je vais
prendre la place cinq sets de gainey
salle de grigny oui il a une très bonne
intuition c'est un magicien ferrat du
fluide
alors vous savez quoi je vais l'ouvrir
direct voilà vous êtes sûr de la saq
ouais bien sûr aller 7 sur l'a52 masque
damas j'adore j'ai dit ouais je faire
donc la tête de the mask gégé qui jouent
le jeu bravo match et mannequin elle est
toujours attention j med beaucoup d'eau
n'emmerde pahlavi beaucoup les jachères
butin clame un bébé ah oui bon à mon
avis non on ira toujours classés je suis
choqué les classes elle même jour
les magnifiques attention la boîte
numéro numéro 3 3 dans la mienne est ce
que je peux changer chef
bien sûr je peux changer donc je prendre
celle de matthew ah non non non non oh
là là là trois ce que vous la presse
est-ce que vous la presse que
voulez-vous les lattois lacroix donc je
vais l'ouvrir directement à tout la
victoire
et ce soir tu vas vite je peux changer
mes brûlures dont un changement et pas
moi j'irai droit à un changement frac
ébahis les changements ton vrai
changement oui j'ai mon changement
hammam
bah je veux l'a8 se fait rare dans ma
carrière jean-michel 50 mal aux jambes
comme il est le plus ancien il a droit
d'où son joug
[Rires]
alors je prends la huit meilleurs choix
je trouve pour le voyage wesley ancien
mac est le meilleur choix
l'atlantis eu un site où vous voulez
quoi on va vous laisser comme salis dont
nous les je ne fais pas ce cas dans les
boîtes pour l'instant voilà la 4e la
volée ou pas sur les jeux qui donnent
leur boîte les ou voilà ce qui pollue
voilà voilà
vous voulez la callas vous voulez la 4e'
sûr aller chier cette merde au bienvenue
chez les ch'tis à avoir un petit déj du
ch'nord c'est à dire eh oui je vous le
dis mon chéri un petit déj du ch'nord
pic c'est à dire une tartine de
maroilles dans le café ça vous plaît
merci beaucoup à tirer
ça vous plaît mais j'adore le nord je
peux manger une histoire folle avec le
maroilles merci jean basset bon et la
fin il a feinté que c'est le meilleur le
maroilles
[Applaudissements]
géraldine et isabelle vous ne partirez
pas avec moi à londres
et vous ne gagnerez pas les billets
d'avion pour new york ballet qui veut
garder sa boîte qui veut garder sa vodka
lee addy voulait garder la note
ouais nature de la 9ème ses peines je ne
sais pas du tout ce qui est dans honey
kelly quel est votre film préféré là
dedans mon film préféré
oui maman j'ai raté l'avion maman j'ai
raté l'avion
ouais et bien kelly kelly vous avez
gâtés un cadeau magnifique mais non et
si machines non et si kelly kelly vous
avez passé de lier une heure trente dans
un parc avec isabelle c'est le cadeau
que la pub on craignait qu'elles d'arc
et kelly l'a eu mais on va les envoyer
dans un parc dans un parc comme ça
évacuation d'un poste municipal va les
patients ne cessa de racontera la guerre
est jeune et ça l'est resté voulait
rester une heure trente sur un bon film
racontera lectorat contrats à l'étranger
vous allez y aller ce week end à monza
et de voilà je pense que vendredi vous
allez passer 1h30 dans un parc tout les
deux ça vous faire du bien à l'équipe de
garder sa boîte mon clément tu regardes
très bonne lagarde
tu gardes ta boîte oui c'est sûr est ce
que c'est que les mots six nouveaux noms
à venir avec moi voir qu margot robbie
sais pas qui c'est
tu as bien le film le joker je les avais
vus et ben tu vas le voir le maquillage
du joker j'adore l'or quant à l
éclatante alors qu'ils avaient les
plateaux sans déconner on dirait qu'elle
tombe est ton p'tit déj à lodève suis
pas chérie tu t'en occupes l'or va s'en
occuper pendant qu'on continue vadim
alors l'orchestré une mcleish la boîte
qu'il veut garder sa boîte allez les
ringards la catin je suis pas sûr bah
ouais j'suis pas sûr
ok alors je la garde ah bah ça nous
ferait du bien de se rapprocher un petit
peu oui bon rapproché petit voyage
outre-manche
bah ouais mais si si si oui les gars
paris il serait bientôt à chaque fois
son fils aux hommes nectar font les
visiteurs a alors vendu ou déguisé
[Applaudissements]
le sourire de chatouilles en mettant du
chocolat sur vos dons à dire ok je
voulais les a balancés que c'est parce
que vous vouliez les chéris il reste des
cadeaux many as oui il reste les billets
d'avion pour new york
le bronzage des bronzés se faire
momifiée et une journée à londres
allez voir margot robbie bach je sais me
sens très bien vous allez avait quand
même
ll elle le fait bien attention fait l'on
regarde aujourd'hui les breaks tu as
quand même que monkey honte année le
poète je lui fais le vrai mathias à
venir le poppy en panne et toutes les
missions quoi il est trop chou c'est
vrai vaste étude où il doit donner des
scoops après ça va le faire ebadi et
clément il m'a dit ça va le faire
réfléchir
il reste la boîte oui la boîte 10 la
boîte trois jardins et la boîte 2 est-ce
que vous avez une préférence
je n'ai pas de préférence franchement je
serais content avec tout le monde
absolument pas ce qui rend les boîtes
alors je vous le dis maintenant il le
sait je le sais mais ça y est je dis la
vérité au pub non je sais ce qu'il ya
dans les vrais alors à vous de voir si
j'ai envie de partir avec vous pas oui
il reste pour partir avec moi maxime
jean michel benjamin ou mathieu cherchez
l'intrus aller maxime est ce que tu
gardes la deux non s'il a changé
tu apprends de quoi on a trois celle de
mathieu et sauf que mais initialement il
a glané vite je me donne tout alors
voilà il a choisi la 3 à temps non mais
ça y est maintenant un an mais ça y est
il a eu droit à deux changements parce
qu'ils étaient plus âgés
j'ai deux changements car je suis
animateur non non pas du tout vous
n'êtes rien du tout et sur maxime allais
ouais là dehors ouais je sais pas ce
qu'il ya dans la 2 je sais pas ce qui
peut croire à la momie au jeu ça oui
pas se faire momifié maxime va attirer
toutes russes très beau être génial je
vais me faire vomir
vous allez voir aller mais que je
voulais que je tombe allez c'est pas
d'abri toi il a l'habitude apparemment
attention les séries il reste trois
cadeaux il reste deux gros cadeau et un
cadeau rip 10 8 et 2 s'ajoutent matthieu
delormeau jean michel mr et benjamin
castaldi qui va partir à londres qui va
gagner les deux billets pour new york
c'est vous parce que les gens n'y
croient pas mais on est lié c'est des
trucs deux mois je crois beaucoup au
sens moi je fais l'acupuncture
d'ésotérisme tout ça a amené les chiens
on élit les boîtes nous ramène résistons
nous ramène le cap en février nous
ramène à des fous jean meyer est ce que
tu gardes à vue thiès ouais bah tu es ce
que tu gardes à deux que tu gardes la
deux est ce que j'aurai un contact
c'est-à-dire un contact je tente quelque
chose pas vraiment savait que ponctuelle
deux secondes je prend la 8
ah non mais non mais non plus
laquelle tu veux non mais j'ai envie de
garder la 10e gagnent là disent tout à
fait des mauvais choix ouais je sais
mais bon change et partira sur elle dit
nous sommes à moins lien2 ya deux très
beaux cas demain je serai je fais cas ce
qu'a dit rastan du mascara mur castaldi
ouest a dit ouais castaldi ouais tu
prends la 10e tu prend la 2 ânes on
regarde la disent tu gardes la dictature
tu vas pas la deux a eu les deux je sais
pas où tu veux pas la [ __ ] à un ballon
bien dans le style je garde la disent
allez tu as un chiffre à donner ce sera
le dernier risque de 1,8
c'est fou c'est comme avec texane n'a
jamais su faire un choix oui disent
d'eux hoowit delà de natation vous
perdez spectacle un peu castaldi mon
chéri lui les sur d'a2a web je ne sais
plus je ne sais pas je ne sais pas alors
tu vois la 2d sur la deux
[Applaudissements]
alors non mais vient pas me doit
s'achever la conjoncture aussi voiture
sans rien du tout où toi alors non je
m'emballe à 2 j'en veux pas haddad
assure a pu à quoi tu voudrais gagner a
le plus appris moi je voudrais bien soin
partir avec vous souhaitez
alors voulez-vous on voulait la dce
données maladie allez on reprend la 10
alors qu'on sait qu'il va perdre
vous voulez quoi moi ouais toi elle
voulait quoi il veut et partira à 8 ou
la disent regardez là demain je garde la
de ma fille il faut que ce soit
quelqu'un qui parle alors est ce que
vous êtes en famille mais attention sur
part à londres on prend un double choix
le train est en panne il ya north one
ton aura plus de deux mois tu es sur
cloud à 2 certains vous êtes stressant
moustoir pas pousse toi oui ça prend la
2 tu prend la 2 oui mais arrête pas là
abondance et qui t'a pas tu n'as deux
matches entre 2 10 et 8 h pour une
invite à aller on était sûr tu veux quoi
lors du mans mais arrachant à l'acte et
les yeux de tes nous tient à la cua la
2e all habitent ou la dc a alors ça sera
là lui tous les sens un pâle à deux
c'est de la merde ça sera là lui tous
les 10 à 10 h 20 ans les yeux je joue au
poker vas-y tu prends dans la viola 10 à
8 et 10 ladislav 8 à 10 dirai plus rien
aux auteurs
il est alors à nager gagner juste garder
la dce arrêter la voiture finit pas sur
toutes les règles alors il a choisi la
di sana vous voulez la deux je ne veux
pas de cadeau rêvé de partir avec vous
voulez à la new york
aussi alors troisième a dit ben je vois
le disent alors je ne m'étais pas fait
l'auvergne et pourra vous dès la 2e' les
plus jeunes je suis perdue alors ouvrez
des deux si vous voulez voit la lettonie
su aller ouvrait la diva la 2a les voilà
voilà deux ouais c'est sûr non 3
mettez-moi en bronze et la deux elle
n'était pas là de paradis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà c'est pour toi
donc voilà avec alors nous une compagnie
qui existe mais c'est dans la soute
les rues étaient en écho regarder ou
comment vous allez partir parce qu'après
là bas vous regarde et qu'on ait voulu
améliorer regarder quand vous allez
partir mais le travail quand même bien
mais c'est quand mais ils disent
24 12 chez 24 chambres à la fin d'année
prochaine avant et donc 2019 s'est passé
c'est raté c'est bien rimer bah oui
parce que si maman j'ai raté l'avion
le bâtard ça fait drôle on en a connu du
pourri
tu sais vraiment c'est là les
branchements franchement blague
alors il reste qu à dix après les
bronzés des bonzes et je vous le dis
c'est se faire un visage bien bronzé ce
qu'on appelle une bernard montiel dans
le métier hélas vite avec le départ à
londres à mes côtés quand vous avez
dadis à traquer alors dissous vite je
vais vous dire comme c'est matthieu
delormeau a énormément parlé
le mot de la fin est le choix de la
boîte ce qu'il en reste deux je vais le
laisser à la sagesse à celui qui avec
moi depuis le début
jean-michel mais est-ce que vous gardez
la [ __ ] ou est ce que vous prenez la 10
est-ce que vous avez un conseiller me
donner conseils que j'ai à vous donner
j'en ai pas mais vous avez fait un geste
comme ça qui montre la disent les faits
j'en ai pas osé tenir important du
langage corporel
ouais je la conseille jamais j'en ai pas
non
voilà elle bat à ok j'ai compris lundi
j'ai pas dis que j'en aie ça je reçu
cinq sur cinq
il m'a dit que j'en avais mais j'ai
peut-être un conseil devait cette boîte
eu c'est fou ça change tout cas veut
dire qu'il va te conseille la traîne
avec méthode et ténacité du sujet pour
la 10e année à 10
stature part est ce que tu es sur wii
dit ça à vos chiffres dit si tu prends
la glisse et lviv ces bâtards et prend
la 17è sur j'appelle comme mathieu doit
mois après la ville dès le début ouais
moi c'est moi la dix jours monsieur je
vais compter jusqu'à 122 milles quand
michel je vais compter jusqu'à 10 avec
tout public
on fera des coûts au bout de ces 10
secondes ce sera ton choix et ton
dernier choix attention 10 nov
mais bernadis c'est vraiment regarde la
deux il a dit ça les gens me jean-michel
est-ce que c'est toi qui va partir avec
moi alors j'en mis les menottes
est ce que tu as envie de partir avec
moi évidemment son rôle évidemment pas
popa pour marjorie pour vous mathieu ce
que tu as envie de partir avec moi
allons devoir cette immense tas tant que
j'y suis allé une fois était en tout cas
vous dire mais il ya une boîte que
j'adore là bas je vous promets ses
besoins barisone fire and fire et non
ses tacles gaz et garçons feu gay
friendly n'y a pas de revanche pas si
vous payez pas l'alcool on va là-bas
c'est le boys and fire mais c'est une
boîte et la base tu fais pas la culture
handball a fait à l'intérieur
[Applaudissements]
il va vivre un autre londres va rentrer
un ordinateur ou bien 4
on sait jamais on peut se chauffer
qu'est ce que j'avais écrit là bas accor
le boys band fine anacarde jean-michel
monte à laisser les 10 secondes
qu'ai je garde la 10e garde m'a dit tu
gardes la dispo chez nous à son bien
mathieu renchérit c'est jean michel qui
a eu le choix
il a choisi de garder la dise ce que
j'ai envie c'est la très très envie
d'aller avec murray à londres services
communs non morale pas s'il y a marqué
une journée à londres avec cyril si tu
gagnes journée à londres avec moi s'il a
marqué les bronzés jean michel saive ce
sera perdu d'ailleurs tu travailles pas
le bronzage des bonzes et tu seras déjà
je faisais moi c'est puni assez puni est
dans un état assez lamentable devrait
comme d'hab je vous le dis c'est jean
michel qui a pris la décision
si j'avais lu il doit leur rendre la vie
tu perdes me casse si tu perds tu te
casses m
j'espère que tu perds le hasard va bien
faire les choses
la dernière fois qu'on a fait les boîtes
matthieu delormeau a gagné en prime time
qui fera le 13 février à mes côtés le
prime time
l'amour veille de saint valentin mathieu
d'autres moi des gens est ce que tu vas
gagner une deuxième fois les boîtes
jean michel est ce que tu vas gagner le
droit d'aller voir margot robbie c'est
ton style margot robbie
j'adore subi mais en plus tous les deux
on fera une belle équipe je pense aussi
et juste peut elle être préféré me voir
moi ou voir jean-michel mais ne connaît
pas parce que tu es mètre 90 go les
stars d'aujourd'hui moment là tu parles
trop même là actuellement je pense pas
que ce soit son principal problème
jean-michel mon chéri c'est ta boîte
j'avais déjà perdu le premier sommet de
la mienne est déjà perdue prague contre
matthew tait dernière après que c'était
celle de benjamin castaldi jouait pas la
changer benjamin castaldi qui ne
voulaient pas sans lui et sa boîte il
voulait pas changer de femme aussi
malheureusement il a toujours été à côté
de la queue plat vous autour de la table
ont préféré que ce soit ils
préféreraient qu'ils soient qui m'a
jamais bas évidemment jean michel jean
michel sophie j'avais dit à benjamin
veut garder la 10 mai cet agent michel
fau michel bien sûr qu'elle y gérait
jean-michel aussi maxime à l'historique
jean-michel bien sûr t'es bon
jean-michel évidemment flatté mais battu
d'une jean michel isabelle michel
moi je veux dire mathieu boys une faille
[Rires]
the fire rien à voir la définition de la
jalousie
mon dieu oui je veux faire quelque chose
que je ne fais jamais ouais je vais te
laisser le dernier choix or c'est toi
qui va décider où le besoin du bâti sa
ferme à 4 heures et à la faim dans ses
bouteilles de champagne bam bam bam tout
le monde et puis on est debout sur le
bar est prouvée s'appelle salbris
l'intérieur ce que tout repart on avait
quelque chose en feu
parce qu'à la fin la fin de la fin tu es
debout sur le bar puis montre tes abdos
et tout le monde et on fire comme ça
avec un avec un truc de lumière dans les
mains et ça fait une grande gerbe de
lumière on appelle ça le boys and fire
est le plus beau celui qui a été élu
marche au milieu du bar comme ça avant
ce sera 3 bien ce sera toi bien sûr
voilà c'est flatteur bon la barre tu vas
vraiment aimé parce que c'est un vrai
menu n'ont ni un jeu pas sûr de faire ce
voyage je leur ai alors mathieu oui tu
fais eh bien tu es bien je vais et si tu
si tu me permet de changer c'est que ces
gens me qui va partir et ça t'emmerde où
tu me permet de changer de zone gp2 je
retiens hasard je prends deux sets de
gens me l'a 10 et sur wii et surtout
pour la 10 non alors là c'est la
dernière fois à l'école 13,5 secondes
aller au clash de l'âge de chant choqué
à il a dissous la alors 5
je prends à 10 4 10 3 10 pas dit je
prends la disent tu penses que je prends
un des blocs 1 pour les maladies comme
si la vie tu es tu là tu peut plus
changer le but sur les fils et filles
est fini il a pris l'habitude il l'avait
c'est donc jean michel capri à 10 qui va
partir avec moi à londres voir margot
robbie mardi on sera de retour dans la
journée
parce qu'on a une émission à faire la
gueule mardi soir mais bon on va qui
fait quand même franchement jean mi
je crois en ma bonne étoile fanta bonne
étoile c'est la boîte de jour me que
j'ai dans les mains
alors c'est la mienne c est à lui seul
tout ton et que c'est pas la tienne
thônex et [ __ ] me soit un boîtier plus
ta boîte quand tu vends une voiturette à
partir du web a lancé jean bie tu aurais
celle de mathieu
[Applaudissements]
ah les joies salle de bain
mathieu c'est que non non non mathieu
pour mathieu je fais mal d'un coup je
montre
je le rentre
fait montrer qu'à toi pour l'instant
à l'école on changea polaire est en
effet 6 1
héritage pour que je cause est perdue je
gagne la tue pas un local
[Applaudissements]
jean michel boucher